so let's start with this the CBS News
poll out this morning shows more than
half of Americans think the partial
government shutdown is causing serious
problems in the u.s. about one in five
reports being personally impacted by the
cutback in services or programs caused
by the shutdown 71 percent of Americans
say building a border wall is not worth
this shutdown that includes 43 percent
of Republicans in our poll
so what's Congress gonna do well GOP and
Democratic leaders are planning separate
votes this week on their plans to reopen
the government but those are not
expected to pass this shutdown is now 33
days old and the entire US economy is
starting to feel the pinch major Garrett
is at the White House with a look the
impact on Americans and those in
government major good morning good
morning the economic ripples from the
shutdown can be found literally across
the country from a chicken wing
restaurant in Maryland to an aerospace
firm in Seattle that restaurant well
it's had to cut back hours for its staff
and that engineering firm has canceled
plans to hire more engineers later this
week this year meanwhile the legislative
tug-of-war continues on Capitol Hill but
that's largely for show we are
predominantly not a government-run
economy we're a free-market economy
true but the president's top economist
Larry Kudlow could not deny mounting
financial worries even inside the White
House I had young people on my staff who
are concerned so I get I get that I
don't want to dance away from that the
White House estimates the shutdown
reduces economic growth by 0.1 3
percentage points each week and that
private economy turns in part on federal
paychecks the ones that have been
missing for nearly a month
I don't Kassie Hassan operations manager
of the America's best wings chain in
Maryland has many restaurants located
near government buildings our clients
are regular customers they're not
showing up from the lunch break and
while the White House says all will
return to normal when the shutdown ends
small business owners across the country
like Robert Hoyt may feel it longer
we've had to let go 12 of our
engineering staff 12 good hard-working
engineers
hoyt seattle-based company tethers
unlimited works with NASA and other
federal agencies
poit cut staffing by 20% because pending
invoices sit unpaid on a furloughed
bureaucrats desk
they were co-workers and friends to us I
expect it'll make it more challenging
for us to bring in new employees some
agency leaders are privately fretting
over a coming brain drain as
high-skilled workers leave for the
private sector and shutdown anxiety
drives away potential hires but those
fears have not been enough to forge a
compromise here you know in the small
business land it feels like we're being
held hostage at the agency level
especially those that deal with security
matters there is growing and yet private
concern that not only this brain drain
but lack of cohesion is going to create
problems that the systems are going to
begin to break down and they're looking
for Congress and this White House to
forge a solution soon Nora and major
what are you hearing from your reporting
about how this may be impacting our
national security well let's talk about
one agency the FBI now the FBI has
there's a group called the FBI agents
Association it's a private independent
organization but it issued a report
yesterday that got quite a bit of
attention that report said nearly 13,000
federal agents and support staff are
furloughed the report said that is
severely impacting the bureau's
organization operations and its ability
to just do day-to-day casework some
agency they fear it is allowing
criminals to go free one agent said his
SWAT team has quote no means of
purchasing critical equipment gear or
ammo for either training or operations
another agent quoted in this report said
the shutdown is hurting our ability to
protect ourselves from those who would
kill us and destroy our way of life it
will come as no surprise to you nor this
group is at urged Congress and the White
House to end the shutdown as soon as
possible restore operations and provide
some measure of financial security for
these agents really alarming major thank
you